it's back I dream about the bug cheeks
every night low to no end and it Springs
me all over dream about your cheeks
every night the left one is called Betty
and like mine is neck I dream about your
cheeks every single day I don't think
that just necessarily makes me a happy
girl
this game come out it's supposed to be
like the full version now and I think
I'm in the game I'm not sure
jacksepticeye told me he's like you're
in the game I killed you and then I'm
like I cry yeah mission one braids
[ __ ] mission one sprays
[ __ ] Wow
this is what I'm talking about girl this
is what I'm what about and talk about
girl I'm about a father go in there as
girl what happened to that car
this just want to think about senpai I
mean what this is what I want to do this
step by step as smack it oh god oh god
oh god okay come on we're not number one
yet are you cereal my milk is running
out goddamn cat got him caps yo whoa
what what was that now it's imagine I'm
number one I'm number one I'm number one
[ __ ] let's make some cars
ah that [ __ ]
look at him he's so disappointed it
cancer what you kick are you serious
I can't believe this and now my fields
just drained out of my body like when I
ate a lot of spicy food
okay now I'm not wearing any helmet and
that's the scene responsible yeah that'd
be great if I could drive that chair
that'd be that'd be a big fan of that
well here we go here we go go go here we
go
and I want a Yolo in my whole low broke
you think you Swedish I tell you all
about Sweden that's it's what we do it's
wait I gotta [ __ ] up no we don't we
barely touch each other Oh God that guy
has a spear no that's a shovel you
shovel [ __ ] a shovel [ __ ] it's like
you all night if you know what I'm
saying
I don't kill [ __ ] don't please don't
police report me this music it's too
epic oh Jesus
Jason Jason Jason what is it with these
camera angles whoa what was that
this epic music
Oh God go face it use your static power
Poots
got'em switch weapons Oh God
I have a what what in the actual [ __ ] is
happening
can someone please explain to me what
people out sorry card sorry about 950
yishun I do diffracting you cannot be
serious
oh we're back we're back in the game
what my bulb I'm cutting fire now I want
to shoot down come on I love this game
so much sorry with a weapon yes Lucy oh
[ __ ] attract the police all right what
do I do to attract the police I can
better get naked or some [ __ ] caps
pay attention to me that's not illegal
they said I never do anything bad I'm
just dancing and you happen to be in my
way I'm dancing over here come on that's
your fault
whoa Jason ah I'm not very good at this
game brass let's do this I've never been
so ready to do something in my tear
laughs boom smack down to my oh I became
Michael Jackson for a minute I
you ask [ __ ] every time hey I just
met you and you're [ __ ] dead
oh no I'm dead oh I got one Wow Wow I'm
number one we're doing approach oh god
oh god I have a shotgun shout eh
okay okay okay uh okay okay we don't do
this just a friendly pat on the back
haha
gosh ha
that's how it's done take out the trash
[ __ ] I'll have a tactical axe
I'll take the tactical ass if you know
what I mean here we go here we go bro
i'ma [ __ ] you in the Rojo slap that bow
with a girl on slap that booty girl what
slap that slap - slap that slap
don't you dare touch me don't you know
who I am that's right I'm the slave
master his hasty come here you little
[ __ ]
come here you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] ah
what all right now you're just being
reading woo hey [ __ ]
hi [ __ ] hi [ __ ] well later oh hi
man i'ma write that whoa is this the
best thing ever look at I said [ __ ]
jet packs amazing amazing
we're all read by every against each
other later dude stop deflecting me
that's what we do it in the port a
pat-down [ __ ] got free health insurance
you'll need it [ __ ]
you'll [ __ ] need it okay stop
deflecting me oh you know what
it's own its own it's our oh jesus dad
weapon kill some count what Oh God
Mike I know one told me my rock god damn
it it's a rocket ship
Wow no I've always liked that bonus map
everybody's like that all day
like Apple is like a balloon live about
a girl Bona Bona Bona Mahna Mahna Mahna
bode dip you're not cacao chocolate
chocolate chocolate no chocolate no fish
duncantucker nose nose dr. chocolate no
it's clear well calm down calm down
gentlemen
you think you can represent Sweden oh
[ __ ] oh maybe you're right bye
ah no why does this happen ship goodbye
ha ha good bike yeah oh Jesus
sorry I'm gonna kill him just kick what
do you think I am
job wait why am i so bloody awesome
hmm I tracked the poopoo huh
I track the poopoo girl hey oh [ __ ] come
on I want to talk to the kicks
what is the cops frog what is wrong with
you
corrupt [ __ ] what what was that
they're crazy
what the hell is that stop it what this
ride with cab
what stop making my way downtown walking
fast faces pass in my hole down what is
wrong with the cops
oh man crap Jesus what what was that
that's ridiculous
9 bit dear [ __ ] me oh we're fine we're
fine we're fine we're fine
whew my mom said I would never get
anywhere without an education she didn't
know but anyway I had a lot of fun
playing this game is really fun uh-oh
people's I fun and watching me play it
and as always thank you for liking this
video it makes me do this sails and
brothers love you